Jaws 4 Halloween 6 and a Good Day to Die
Hard three different ways to say
nobody's favorite movie these franchises
started out with Incredible debuts and
ended up as tired jokes could can you
stop him talking like that as there a
switch or something the first time you
see Freddy Krueger it's the scariest
night of your life the last time you see
him he's like a bad comedian and you
want to beo off the stage how about this
back Robert England's iconic performance
as Freddy made a creepy who needs some
lotion into a horror movie Legend the
first movie success single-handedly
established new line Cinema which kept
the nightmare train going with sequel
after Sequel and every one of these
sequels was a little bit dumber than the
last you Scarface lint
dick The Kills get far too silly and
Freddy's backstory as the son of 100
Maniacs starts to become something only
a maniac could understand it's still one
of the greatest horror franchises and
Freddy has a spot on the Mount Rushmore
of slash of villains right next to Jason
VES and Thomas Jefferson but new Line's
determination to ring every last dollar
out of the franchise drained this
monster of its power I just keep on
checking the last new movie in this
series was a 2010 reboots that brought
nothing to the table but things we've
seen before the original Die Hard is one
of the greatest action movies ever made
and its sequels are things that exist
Die Hard 2 started the die hard but in a
blank Trend by doing die hard but in an
airport the third movie is an inspired
buddy romp through a Manhattan wide
string of action sequences but after
that the whole thing fell off a
[Music]
[Applause]
cliff the first three die hards are
relatively grounded for action movies
Bruce Willis may be fighting on the wing
of a plane but if he falls off he's
definitely going to die by the fourth
movie he can just kill planes she just
killed a helicopter with a car I was out
of bullets it's bad enough for and black
widow can somehow survive concussive
impacts that should shatter every bone
in her
body at least she's an Avenger but John
mlan is no superhero he's a schlubby
tired cop who happens to be in the right
place at the wrong time in the first
movie shouts of Glass on the floor are a
serious problem by the fifth one John is
all but mortal a poor man's Captain
America who's lost all of his charm
before we get started does anyone want
to get out speaking of normal people who
become complet completely unkillable I
don't have friends I got family everyone
knows the Arc of The Fast and Furious
movies they started out being about
street racing and simple heists the DVD
players were purchased legally all we've
got on TR and Company are some
outstanding speeding tickets five movies
in they became movies where literally
Anything Could
Happen we're going to need a bigger
truck it started out as great fun but by
the eighth movie things became not so
fast and way too serious the era of
literal superhumans and launching cars
into space we're out of space should
have seen the series at its most wacky
but now they feel bloated like they've
taken too many steroids much like the
runway in fast INF Furious 6 movies in
the series have become impossibly long
they're also incredibly expensive in
fact fast xeg cost so much to make here
we go that it was a bug serice
disappointment despite bringing in well
over half a billion dollars much like di
hard Jurassic Park is a legitimately
great movie with a lot of sequels it
doesn't need following the first film's
meteoric success Universal Studios mined
more fossil fuel with a Lost World
Jurassic Park and Jurassic Park 3 Alan
neither film came anywhere close to the
quality of the original the series went
dormant until Chris Pratt perhaps the
most mid of Hollywood Chris's brought
his hurah charm to Jurassic world
essentially a remake of the original
movie but with 100% more Jimmy Buffett
this new entry in the franchise was a
runaway hit it spawned two SE sequels
neither of which were well received by
critics Jurassic world not a fan
Jurassic world Dominion in particular
had a bizarre plot about dinosaur
preservation genetically modified
children and giant Locust swarms and yet
it still managed to break a billion
dollars at the box office Shame about
the 29% on Rotten Tomatoes though your
scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they didn't
stop to think of they sh no one really
thinks of Jaws as a slasher movie but
the sequels somehow have the worst
versions of every slasher Trope they
made lepre corn in space look like The
Godfather Part
Two Steven Spielberg's 1975 Thriller was
a massive hit and redefined what it
meant to be a summer blockbuster
Universal seems to have a thing for
taking classic films and diluting them
to the point of parody and the Jaws
franchise might be the worst offender
bloody hell get started dou the breath
on that thing though it could be argued
that there are legitimate fans of Jaws 2
out there somewhere jaws 3D and Jaws to
Revenge can only be watched ironically
the fourth and final movie in the series
is definitely the most baffling if a
killer shark isn't wild enough try one
with psychic abilities and a serious
Grudge I have one simple request and
that is to have sharks with freaking
laser beans attached to their heads
there would be no slasher movies without
John Carpenter's Halloween there would
be movies about people killing people
sure but Michael Myers first massacre
laid the groundwork for an entire genre
the original Halloween is great and
Halloween 2 is perfectly fine but
depending on who you ask Halloween 3
season of the witch is either a morbidly
funny gem or a stain on the series name
instead of Michael Myers the villain of
the third movie is an Irish warlock who
wants to turn kids heads into bugs I do
love a good joke and this is the best
ever a joke on the children after that
bombed fans demanded the return of
Michael Myers but you know what they say
be careful what you wish for with
Halloween 4 the return of Michael Myers
the single-minded serial killer was back
and more generic than ever it also
started a NeverEnding trend of reccon
story arcs wasn't it her brother no
that's just a bit that some people made
up when Executives decided to wash their
hands of Michael's convoluted past and
start fresh there was apparently no one
better to direct than the man who
invented slamming in the back of the
Dragula Rob Zombie helmed two Halloween
films in the late 2000s giving Michael a
white trash backstory and when David
Gordon green took over a decade later he
just threw everything that wasn't
Carpenters original all completely out
the window there's nothing to learn
there are no new insights at this point
the Halloween timeline is about as
simple as AP Calculus even though the
series supposedly ended in Halloween
ends the entire Halloween franchise has
become a stalking Menace that no one
seems capable of Killing For Good
decades before Brendan Fraser won an
Oscar for getting sweaty in a fat suit
he battled an undead Egyptian priest in
the reboot of universals The Mummy this
wasn't your mummy's mummy either emot
remains a scary villain to this day
provided you stop following the story at
the end of the first movie the 1999
mummy movie made a boatload of money but
the sequels couldn't avoid falling into
all of the typical pitfalls in The Mummy
Returns the scariest thinging on screen
was Dwayne the rug Johnson looking like
a character from Mortal Kombat on the
PlayStation
2 after that there was nothing Tob of
the Dragon Emperor could do to save the
sinking ship and the series was pushed
into obscure director DVD scorpion King
spin-offs that were doomed to haunt
bargain bins in Walmarts Across America
Universal attempted to bring the
franchise back with the Tom crw starring
reboots that kicked off The Dark
Universe that's right the Dark Universe
the Beloved Cinematic Universe that
includes a remake of The Mummy and
literally nothing else we'll never get
to see Russell Crow and Dr Jackal and Mr
Hyde but judging by the sad attempt to
resurrect The Mummy for a quick Buck it
doesn't seem like a massive loss unless
of course you Russell Crow it's not an
exact science this business
and the business being evil horror
movies don't get much better than alien
and action movies don't get much better
than aliens however many movies are
better than Alien 3 and alien
resurrection and alien Covenant so where
did things first go wrong Alien 3 or as
some call it alien cubed was stuck in
development hell for ages with writers
and directors entering and exiting like
it was a revolving door at Applebee's
they eventually landed on a rookie
filmmaker by the name of David Fincher
who was still a few years away from
making an actually decent movie Alien 3
made its way to Cinemas in 1992 but it
immediately Drew criticism by killing
off two fan favorite characters within
the first 5 minutes the series had a
brief creative Revival and Ridley Scott
returned with Prometheus which ended up
being alien without the alien when the
xenomorph as we know it finally did make
its dramatic return in Alien Covenant
Scott was still so stuck on the
philosophical plot lines of Prometheus
that it felt like a chore to watch
despite the past 30 years of alien flops
ruined by The NeverEnding quest for
profit some fans still hold out hope
that Fay Alvarez's upcoming alien flick
alien Romulus might actually be good
rley Scott says that he loves what he's
seen But then again he also loved
putting Guy Pierce in freaky old man
makeup very negative way of looking at
things exactly why you should have
stayed at home when Will Smith and Tommy
Lee Jones first put on the suits and
sunglasses for 1997's men in black
success seemed all but guaranteed in the
years since Studio Executives have tried
to recapture the magic but it seems they
looked directly into the neuralyzer and
forgotten what it is that actually made
the original so good in an interview
with den of geek Men In Black
screenwriter Ed Solomon gave his take on
what makes Men In Black so special
saying I always felt like the secret to
Men In Black was not the sunglasses and
the big guns and the coolness and the
other surface level coolness of it I
always thought the secret of Men In
Black was the generosity of spirit
unfortunately all the things that didn't
Define finally original for Solomon
became the franchise's identity and it
started to Flounder with its sequels the
series had the potential to take a big
swing when it was announced that it
could be crossing over with 21 Jump
Street but the project ended up getting
canned instead we got the incredibly
mediocre Men In Black International the
second worst saw Ragnarok reunion just
behind love and
thunder unless the next one finds a way
to bring back Vincent daario's fan
favorite alien bugman we've probably
seen all we need to see of men
black is that letter James Cameron is
probably the closest thing we have to a
real life wizard he creates magical
worlds and bends the box office to his
will so naturally his Terminator series
fell apart when he moved on the
Terminator introduced millions of people
to Austrian strongman Arnold
Schwarzenegger that's a terrifying
killer Cyborg and Terminator 2 Judgment
Day chains up the formula by turning him
into a terrifying killer cyborg that you
could trust to watch you kid both films
were smashed hits that massively
multiplied their budgets T2 made over
half a billion dollars on a budget of
around $100 million and that's not
counting all the kids who snuck into the
theater after paying for Bill and Ted's
Bogus Journey check this
out after that Cameron was done Direct
in the series so he moved on to big
boats and cap people of course Fox
couldn't let such a big earner go
unexploited Terminator 3 rise of the
Machines was the beginning of the end
but at least it actually had swatz and
EGA in it the same couldn't be for
Terminator Salvation in 2009 which was
when the movies truly started to feel
like cash grabs even Arie couldn't save
the series when he came back for
Terminator Genesis you assho James
Cameron returned as a producer for 2019s
Terminator dark fate but the newest
sequel came nowhere close to the first
two films so you're Carl that's what
everyone calls me yes it seems that any
possibility for the series to return to
its former glory has been
squashed
what you think I was going to say
terminated you're wrong you're
terminated